creators have uh off-platform Behavior
or there's off-platform news that could
be damaging to the broader Creator
ecosystem you can be suspended from our
monetization program Neil Mohan is the
new Youtube CEO and he's very happy that
they demonetized Russell Brand Russell
Brand who by the way has not been
convicted of any crime uh he's just been
accused of some things but they as a
company have decided that he's not
allowed to make a
living Monday on CBS morning's our
exclusive interview with the CEO of
YouTube he talked about a number of
things including his decision to block
Russell Brand from collecting ad money
from his YouTube videos the move was
made after four women accused brand of
sexual assault allegations he denies we
asked bran to respond to YouTube's
decision in the latest allegations but
we have not heard back here's part of
Tony's conversation with Youtube CEO
Neil
Mohan we have a a Creator responsibility
guidelines uh policy where if creators
have uh off-platform Behavior or there's
off platform for news that could be
damaging to the broader Creator
ecosystem you can be suspended from our
monetization program uh it's impacted a
number of uh creators and personalities
on the platform uh in the past and
that's what played out in this
particular case around the serious
allegation it's an accusation it's not a
police charge it's not a a legal
decision how do you decide when to step
in before the whole due process has
happened we Endeavor to apply those
rules uh equally across our entire
Creator ecosystem not playing favorites
having them apply to the content the
behavior as opposed to who the person is
lies lies lies lies there's nothing but
lies there and the fact that what they
are saying is what you do off
platform will dictate whether you could
make a living or be heard on this
platform is so freaking dangerous think
how stupid this is or not it's not
stupid it's evil think how evil this is
imagine if there was a guy who let's say
he actually stole an apple from a
grocery store and he worked at a shoe
store he was a shoe salesman and for
whatever reason he stole an apple do you
think that he should no longer be
allowed to create YouTube videos see how
those things are all wildly disconnected
but that's in essence what they're
saying if you do something we don't like
you wait you're a shoe salesman who
stole an apple you can't make YouTube
videos that's if the guy stole the Apple
there's no evidence that Russell Brand
did anything it's a it's besides the
point but the idea that off
platform man it's so dangerous these
people are liars and what are you saying
Neil Mohan so someone could just make up
Neil Mohan molested me well I guess Neil
Mohan can't make money on YouTube but
don't worry I'm sure you make several
million to to you know have the the job
that you have you liars I hate
these people there goes our
modernization for today I walked right
into that
one